es un concepto erróneo común que los
niveles en precios están dictados
puramente por la cantidad de dinero que
hay afuera y para ver que este no es el
caso
imaginemos una isla que tiene a dos
jugadores en ella tiene a un granjero
que obviamente producirá comida y a un
propietario constructor que te puede
rentar edificios o construirse edificios
y estamos imaginando vivir en un
escenario donde lo único que necesitas
es comida y un hogar ahora imaginemos
una realidad en la que esta isla país o
como le quiera llamar no han descubierto
mucho oro solo tienen un poco de moneda
así que quizás el granjero solo tiene un
par de monedas para empezar y el
constructor propietario constructor
también solo tiene un par de monedas
para empezar no tienen muchas monedas
solo tiene un poco pero sin embargo son
muy optimistas y como son optimistas el
granjero dice el propietario todo está
perfecto en estos momentos quiero rentar
una propiedad para mi familia y para qué
puedas construir más viviendas toma
propietario consultor estas monedas y
construye menos rentable algo lindo así
que el propietario constructor recibe
dos monedas
entonces el constructor piensa oh wow
las cosas van súper el granjero parece
bastante optimista y dice el granjero
quiero que me siempre es una tonelada de
korrika comida porque todo marcha
perfecto así que tomas cuatro monedas y
siembra para mí una tonelada de
deliciosa comida ya sabes comida rara
exótica que casi no aparece por aquí
entonces el granjero recibe esas cuatro
monedas y claro tacho estas dos porque
estos no las tiene se la dio al al
constructor y ahora el granjero se
siente contento feliz genial muy
optimista también borró esto de acá
porque es el así se les diga al granjero
bueno el constructor se la dio granjero
pero bueno con todo esto el granjero
dice el propietario me siento aún mejor
porque no me construyes unas cuantas
viviendas más quiero expandir mi casa
pero ahora el constructor dice granjero
ya me diste mucho dinero y tengo mucho
trabajo debes pagar más si quieres que
trabaje horas extras porque esto me
quitará tiempo con mi familia y también
descanso así que el granjero dice claro
el constructor la última vez te pague
dos monedas de oro por unas viviendas
ahora te pagaré tres monedas de oro por
la misma cantidad de viviendas
entonces obteniendo lo que antes recibía
por dos monedas de oro ahora le va a dar
tres monedas de oro así que si lo
piensas el precio ha subido por
cualquier servicio del constructor y el
constructor dice ahora que tienen las
tres monedas super tengo mucho trabajo
me está yendo genial gracias al granjero
y se le ocurre y quiero comprar más
comida entonces va con el granjero y le
dice dame lo que me diste que ya ves por
dos monedas de oro y el granjero le dice
oye sabes no puedo me tendrías que pagar
horas extras tengo mucho trabajo
constructor entonces si quieren mis
servicios deben darme tres monedas de
oro y el constructor se dio ahora note
en este vídeo iniciamos con solo dos
monedas de oro para cada jugador pero
gracias a su confianza lo siguieron
gastando no con el otro hubo muchas
transacciones hubo tal velocidad en el
dinero que hubo aumento en los precios